hi
i'm lynn clark and i make code cartoons
i also work at fastly which is doing a
ton of cool things with webassembly to
make better edge compute possible
and i'm a co-founder of the bytecode
alliance we're working on tools for a
webassembly ecosystem
that extends beyond the browser and is
one of those tools that i wanted to talk
to you about today
javascript was first created to run in
the browser so that people could add a
little bit of interactivity to their web
pages
no one would have guessed that 20 years
later people will be using javascript to
build all sorts of
big complex applications to run your
browser
what made this possible is that
javascript in the browser
runs a lot faster than it did two
decades ago
and that happened because the browser
vendors spent that time working on
some pretty intense intensive
performance optimizations
now this started with the introduction
of just-in-time compilers around 2008
and the browsers have built on top of
that continuing these optimization
efforts
now we're starting work on optimizing
javascript performance
for an entirely different set of
environments where different rules apply
and this is possible because of
webassembly so today i want to explain
what it is about webassembly that
enables this but first
i want to give you a heads up this talk
is structured a bit differently
than speaking experts would tell me i
should be structuring this presentation
i'm going to start with telling you how
we're making this work at all
and once you've heard that you might not
be on board you might think that this is
a pretty ridiculous idea
so that's why i'm going to explain why
i'm going to explain why you would
actually want to do this
and then once you're bought in and i
know you'll be bought in
then i'm going to come back and explain
exactly how it is that we're making this
fast
so let's get started with how we're
running javascript
inside a webassembly engine
whenever you're running javascript the
js code
needs to be executed as machine code in
one way or another
now this is done by the js engine using
a variety of different techniques
from interpreters and git compilers
and i explained this all in more detail
in my first set of
articles about webassembly back in 2017
so if you want to understand more about
how this works you can go back and read
those articles
running this javascript code is really
quite easy in environments like the web
where you know that you're going to have
a javascript engine available
but what if your target platform doesn't
have a javascript engine
then you need to deploy your javascript
engine with your code
and so that's what we need to do to
bring javascript to these different
environments
so how do we do this well we deploy the
javascript engine as a webassembly
module
and that makes it portable across a
bunch of different machine architectures
and with wazzy we can make it portable
across a bunch of different operating
systems as well
this means that the whole javascript
environment is bundled up into
the webassembly module and once you
deploy it all you need to do
is feed in the javascript code and that
javascript engine will run that code
now instead of working directly on the
machine's memory like it would for
a browser the javascript engine puts
everything from bytecode to the garbage
collected objects that the bytecode
works on
into the webassembly memory's linear
memory
for our js engine we went with spider
monkey and that's the js engine that
firefox uses
it's one of the industrial strength
javascript virtual machines
because it's been battle tested in the
browser and this kind of battle testing
and investment in security is really
important
when you're running untrusted code or
running code that processes
untrusted input spydermonkey also uses a
technique called precise stack scanning
which is important for some of the
optimizations
i'll be describing a bit later in the
talk
so far there's nothing revolutionary
about the approach that i've described
people have already been running
javascript inside of webassembly like
this for
a number of years the problem is
that it's slow webassembly doesn't allow
you to dynamically generate
new machine code and run it from within
pure webassembly code
so this means that you can't use the jet
you can only use the interpreter
now given this constraint you might be
asking why
since jits are how the browsers made js
code run fast
and since you can't jit compile inside
of a webassembly module
this just doesn't make sense but what if
even given these constraints we could
actually make
this javascript run fast let's look at a
couple of use cases where a fast version
of this approach could be really useful
there are some places where you can't
use a just-in-time compiler
due to security concerns so for example
ios devices or some smart tvs and gaming
consoles
on these platforms you have to use an
interpreter
but the kinds of applications that you
run on these platforms are long running
and they require lots of code
and those are exactly the kinds of
conditions where historically you
wouldn't want to use an interpreter
because of how much it slows down your
execution
if we can make our approach fast then
these developers
could use javascript on gitless
platforms without taking a massive
performance hit
now there are other places where using a
jit isn't a problem
but where startup times are prohibitive
so an example of this is in serverless
functions and this
plays into that cold start latency
problem that you might have heard people
talking about
even if you're using the most paired
down javascript environment
which is an isolate that just starts up
a bare javascript engine
you're looking at about five
milliseconds of startup latency
now there are some ways to hide this
startup latency
for an incoming request but it's getting
harder tied as connection times are
being optimized in the network layer
with proposals such as quick
and it's also harder to hide when you're
chaining different serverless functions
together
but more than this platforms that use
these kinds of techniques to hide
latency
also often reuse instances between
requests
and in some cases this means that global
state can be observed between different
requests
which can be a security issue and
because of this cold start problem
developers
also often don't follow best practices
they stuff a lot of functions into one
serverless deployment
so this results in another security
issue which is a larger blast radius
if one part of the serverless deployment
is exploited the attacker has access to
everything in that deployment
but if we can get javascript startup
times low enough in these contexts
then we wouldn't need to hide startup
times with any tricks we could just
start up an instance in microseconds
with this we can provide a new instance
for each request
which means that there's no state lying
around between requests
and because the instances are so
lightweight developers could
feel free to break up their code into
fine-grained pieces
and this would bring their blast radius
down to a minimum for any single piece
of code
so for these use cases there's a big
benefit to making javascript on wasm
fast
but how can we do that in order to
answer that question
we need to understand where the
javascript engine spends its time
we can break down the work that a
javascript engine has to do
into two different parts
initialization and runtime
i think of the js engine as a contractor
this contractor is retained to complete
a job and that job is
running the javascript code and getting
to a final result
before this contractor can actually
start running the project though it
needs to do a little bit of preliminary
work
this initialization phase includes
everything that only needs to happen
once at the very start of the project
so one part of this is application
initialization for any project
the contractor needs to take a look at
the work that the client wants it to do
and then set up the resources that it
needs in order to complete that job
so for example the contractor reads
through the project briefing and other
supporting documents
and turns them into something that it
can work with
so this might be something like setting
up the project management system with
all of the documents stored and
organized and breaking things into tasks
that go into the task management system
in the case of the js engine this work
looks more like reading through the top
level of source code and parsing
functions into bytecode
or allocating memory for the variables
that are declared and setting values
where they're already defined
so that's application initialization but
in some cases there's also engine
initialization
and you see this in contexts like
serverless the js engine itself needs to
be started up in the first place
and built-in functions need to be added
to the environment
i think of this like setting up the
office itself
doing things like assembling the ikea
chairs and tables
and everything else in the environment
before starting the work
now this can take considerable time and
that's part of what can make the cold
start
such an issue for serverless use cases
once the initialization phase is done
the js engine can start its work
this work of running the code and the
speed of this part of the work is called
throughput
and this throughput is affected by lots
of different variables so for example
which language features are being used
whether the code behaves predictably
from the js engine's point of view
what sorts of data structures are used
and whether or not the code runs long
enough to benefit from the js engine's
optimizing compiler
so these are the two phases where the js
engine spends its time
initialization and runtime
now how can we make the work in these
two phases
go faster let's start with
initialization can we make that fast
and spoiler alert yes we can
we used a tool called wiser for this and
i'll explain how that works in a minute
but first i want to show you some of the
results that we saw
we tested with a small markdown
application and using wiser
we were able to make startup time six
times faster
if we look in more depth at this case
about eighty percent of this
was spent on engine initialization
and the remaining twenty percent was
spent on application initialization
and part of that is because this
markdown render is a very small and
simple application
as apps get larger and more complex
application initialization time
just takes longer so we would see even
larger comparative speed ups
for real world applications
now we get this fast startup using a
technique called snapshotting
before the code is deployed as part of
the build step
we run the javascript code using the
javascript engine to the
end of the initialization phase and at
this point the js engine has parsed all
of the js bytecode
or js and turned it into bytecode
which the js engine module stores in the
linear memory
and the engine also does a lot of memory
allocation and initialization in this
phase
because this linear memory is so
self-contained
once all the values have been filled in
we can just take that memory and attach
it as a data section
to a wasm module when the js engine
module is instantiated
it has access to all of the data in the
data section
whenever the engine needs a bit of that
memory it can copy the section or rather
the memory page that it needs into its
own linear memory
with this the js engine doesn't have to
do any setup when it starts up
all of this is pre-initialized ready and
waiting for it to start its work
currently we attach the data section to
the same module as the js
engine but in the future once
webassembly module linking is in place
we'll be able to ship the data section
as a separate module
so this provides a really clean
separation and allows the js
engine module to be reused across a
bunch of different js applications
the js engine module only contains the
code for the engine
that means that once it's compiled that
code can be effectively cached
and reused between lots of different
instances
now on the other hand the application
specific module
contains no webassembly code it only
contains the linear memory
which in turn contains the javascript
vice bytecode
along with all of the rest of the js
engine state that was initialized
this makes it really easy to move this
memory around and send it wherever it
needs to go
it's kind of like the js engine
contractor doesn't need to set up its
own office at all it just gets this
travel case shipped to it
and that travel case has the whole
office with everything in it all set up
and ready to go
for the js engine to just get to work
and the coolest thing about this is that
it doesn't rely on anything that's js
dependent
it's just using an existing property of
webassembly itself
so you could use the same technique with
languages like python or ruby or lua
and other runtimes too
so with this approach we can get to this
super fast startup time
but what about throughput well for some
use cases the throughput is actually not
too bad
if you have a very short running piece
of javascript it wouldn't go through the
jit anyways
it would stand the interpreter the whole
time so in that case
the throughput would be about the same
as in the browser
and so this will have finished before a
traditional javascript engine would have
finished initialization in the case
where you need to do
engine initialization but for
longer running javascript it doesn't
take all that long before the jit starts
kicking in
and once this happens the throughput
difference does become pretty obvious
now as i said before it's not possible
to jit compile code within
a pure webassembly module at the moment
but it turns out that we can apply some
of the same thinking that comes with
just-in-time compilation
to and ahead of time compilation model
one optimizing technique that jits use
is inline caching which i also explained
in my first series about webassembly
when the same bit of code gets
interpreted over and over and over again
the engine decides to store its
translation for that bit of code
to reuse next time and this stored
translation is called the stub
now these subs are chained together into
a linked list
and they're based on what types are used
for that particular
invocation the next time that the code
is run the engine will check through
this list to see whether or not it
actually has a translation
that is available for those types
and if so it'll just reuse this dub
because ice subs are commonly used in
jets
people think of them as being very
dynamic and specific to each program
but it turns out that they can be
applied in an aot context
too before we see the javascript code we
already know a lot of the ic stubs that
we're going to need to use
and to generate and that's because there
are some patterns in javascript that
just get used a whole lot
a good example of this is accessing
properties on objects
this happens a lot in javascript code
and it can be sped up by using an ic
stub
for objects that have a certain shape or
hidden class
that is where the properties are laid
out in the same order
when you get a particular property from
those objects that property will always
be at the same offset
now traditionally this kind of ic stub
in the jet would hard code
two values the pointer to the shape
and the offset of the property that
requires information that we don't have
ahead of time
but what we can do is parameterize the
ic stub
so we can treat the shape and the
property offset as variables that get
passed
in for the stub and this way we create a
single stub that loads values from
memory
and then use that same stub code
everywhere we can just
bake all of the stubs for these common
patterns into the aot compiled module
regardless
of what the javascript is actually doing
and we discovered that with just a
couple of kilobytes of ic stubs we can
cover the vast
majority of all js code for example with
two kilobytes of ic stubs we can cover
95 percent
of the javascript in google's octane
benchmark
and from preliminary tests that percent
percentage seems to hold up
for general web browsing as well
now this is just one example of a
potential optimization that we can make
right now we're in the same kind of
position that the browser js engines
were in
in the early days when they were first
experimenting with
just-in-time compilers in the first
place we still have
a lot of work to do to find the clever
shortcuts that we can use
in this context but we're excited to be
starting that work and excited for the
changes to come
if you're excited like we are about this
and want to contribute to the
optimization efforts
or if you want to try to make this work
for another language like python or ruby
or lua
we'd be happy to hear from you you can
find us on the messaging platform
zulip and feel free to post there if you
want to ask for more info
you can also find links to the projects
that i mentioned in my recently
published blog post on the bytecode
alliance blog
i want to say thank you to the
organizers for inviting me to speak here
today
and thank you all for listening